à les regarder on ne se doute pas que
dans ces sucreries
on retrouve dans la liste d'ingrédients
du cannabis alors on fait de tout on
passe vraiment dû jujubes au swing gum
ou biscuits cru on arrive à faire à peu
près tout ce qui est possible
simon salomone et chef pâtissier à la
croix verte une clinique qui utilisent
le cannabis à des fins médicales depuis
dix ans ce que vous goûtez à vos
produits
ça arrive surtout au début c'est arrivé
maintenant j'ai vite sur ton père de
production maintenant qu'il est possible
d'acheter légalement du cannabis à des
fins récréatives
vous pourriez être tenté d'en intégrer
dans des préparations comestibles comme
des brownies ou des biscuits mais avant
de sortir vos chaudrons
écoutez bien les mises en garde du
chercheur françois olivier hébert
biologiste moléculaire je travaille à
l'université laval comme chercheur
postdoctoral la faculté de médecine au
département de microbiologie
qu'est ce que c'est le cannabis est une
plante qui produit plusieurs centaines
de composés biochimiques qui sont
extrêmement variés le thc est le plus
connu sous les cultes qui donne l'effet
psychotropes du cannabis donc nous les
fait fumer ou manger du cannabis c'est
loin d'être la même chose
qu'est ce qui arrive quand on fume du
cannabis et molécules qui sont activés
sous la chaleur vont rentrer dans notre
jeu va transférer immédiatement dans ce
sens qui va aller très rapidement par
exemple aussi l'effet va se faire sentir
en 30 et 120 secondes après la
consommation
quand on mange du cannabis qui est
transformée au foie finalement c'est
comme si on se trouvait à amplifier son
effet par rapport à la fumée tu as peut
prendre entre 30 et 120 minutes par
exemple pour faire effet c'est une
grosse différence assez importante quand
on mange du cannabis c'est possible j'ai
beaucoup plus longtemps que si on fait
pour ce qu'il faut faire attention aux
doses ici à la croix verte
le dosage est calculé de façon
extrêmement précise
un défi principal c'est le micro dosage
c'est d'arriver à travailler le produit
pour le dire est toujours le même du
début à la fin et surtout d'arriver à
l'incorporer dans la recette tout en le
diluant dans un corps gras ou sucrés
si notre chef pâtissier connaît bien les
quantités de cannabis a utilisé dans ses
pâtisseries ça risque d'être différent
dans le confort de votre cuisine
c'est sûr que si on
je sais un gros match de cannabis dans
une casserole avec une ou deux livres de
bar puis qu'on fait chauffer 100 m
brasse 1 on n'a aucune idée vraiment du
pourcentage de transfert des molécules
finalement de la plante
il se peut alors qu'il y ait trop de thc
dans votre préparation
le conseil que j'aurais à donner c'est
de prendre des doses qui paraissent
infimes au départ puis de voir comment
on réagit de continuer après le plus fou
être patients s'il faut être très
patient on en mange on essaie le à une
deux heures trois heures j'ai pas senti
des ferments justement les gens ils font
l'erreur hermange le double la quantité
qu'ils ont mangé mais non il faut
reprendre exactement la quantité qu'on a
pris et qui nous a pas fait est fait et
puis leur savoir-faire effet le thc
n'agit pas de la même façon sur un
estomac vide ou plein souvent qu'on
consomme du cannabis par ingestion par
exemple après le repos qui a été assez
copieux les fait se sentir super
lentement puis arrive très prétend
versus manger sain qui est une des
meilleures façons de se péter un bad
trip de cannabis page 1 instantanément
le sang ça se peut que ça picchu ça part
vite là
d'autres facteurs influencent les effets
du cannabis la teneur en thc l'état
physique de la personne son habitude à
consommer ou non cette drogue
la prise d'alcool ou de médicaments si
l'effet est trop fort qu'est ce qu'on
fait je m'inquiète pas c'est normal de
s'inquiéter mais faut pas paniquer non
plus parce qu'il n'y a rien de grave qui
peut penser que là je dis aux gens
d'encadrer la personne restée proche
s'assurer que tout va bien rigoler un
peu donc il faut quand même essayer de
stimuler cet aspect le qui peut se
concentrer sur leur âge me sens premier
il peut y avoir des soucis
déshydratation le peut-être donné
beaucoup d'eau et puis d'autres types de
nourriture pour essayer de ralentir la
digestion
le cannabis est bien meilleure sous
modération que sous accès c'est un jeune
avec l'alcool
[Musique]